so let me switch to English because
Bridget will be speaking in English
Bridget represents Google for
entrepreneurs so she'll turn your words
about that and she wants to share her
ideas on which on what game candidates
put up our lives so please Bridget come
on fake um hello i'm brigitte purchasing
i work on this team google for
entrepreneurs I'm instead of Google's
headquarters in California um a little
bit about my team before I get started I
I don't want to bore you too long um but
it's a great team we basically focus on
how Google can foster entrepreneurship
around the world how we can help you
provide you the resources the program's
the partners opportunities you need to
be successful this is our website on if
you ever have a chance it's actually
super useful we put on these classes
online which are free and these are
normally paid classes a lot of them are
top five lawyers and product managers
marketers also many of them are taught
by experts outside of Google and we
released one every week pretty much so
if you follow us on Google+ we put up
new content all the time we also have
great events so if you have a chance you
can check out some of the events like
this that are here again we also post
those to Google+ so if you guys are
interested it's really about bringing
Google errors and our talent to you to
help you be successful that's what today
is about so please have questions ask
them all the Googlers in the room can
you please raise your hand see there's a
lot the ratio is quite high you wear but
there are a lot of people here to help
so please ask questions first of all
goose who is willing to volunteer and
tell me why you're here or give me your
pitch what is your company you yeah okay
here we go hi everybody I'm Rafael from
speech oh and then I'm here to a lot of
approvals and the play I wouldn't push
it wait doesn't go Michael Tamia is a
witch we're making it a bitch so this so
it's like a way to take notes even more
efficient way thank you alright the
question was why people does this is a
good question so if you think about who
was a search engine um we need really
great content out there to make the web
really valuable right if you search and
there's nothing there or if you're
trying to find an application and
there's nothing there for you it's not
very useful Google is very much a
platform for other people to succeed as
much as we succeed all right we only
succeeded by trainers do so that's what
its program exists that makes sense
anybody else wants volunteer I promise
I'll talk about something else a minute
but I want some examples for my
presentation huh oh wait in the back can
you yell all right hey everyone my name
is Jerry and I a phonebook yes what so
you can own it with us thank you recycle
so we fight recited reviews people
besides my recipes 20 plus so I would
think I'm good we had made by people
with google checkout never get me
through my education hundred head over
here and Android I wanna show to have a
good reference you can bring people is
going to be super busy today okay sounds
good well what I want to talk about
today um I am an entrepreneur myself I
work with 20 entrepreneurial spirit in
spending one is my husband
one is my mother there's a lot of things
like my family has a ton of businesses
everybody is running around making
things helping people doing stuff so I
on a daily basis actually help monitor
boss pages Edwards analytics all of the
above so today I actually want to share
with you some of mine I don't have very
much time to do this I have a full-time
job it's probably more like two
full-time jobs and it is something I do
on the side you're also very very busy
informed right and you need to know what
kind of decisions to make on a daily
basis so I'm actually just going to
share a little bit about what I do every
day with my my family's businesses to
help them and I think it's really
valuable for you as an entrepreneur so I
want to talk about data all right it's a
very hot topic everybody loves talk
about data and infographics but very
very few good time did they find it
useful data being useful so our talk
about a few forces first everybody likes
numbers I'll share some cool google
numbers with you but essentially we all
know the world has changed there's a
blog out there called like failed
dinners have you guys seen this okay
it's basically a bunch of people or
people on a date who go out to dinner
together and they spend the whole time
on their phone people like take pictures
with them and then they send it to this
blog section hilarious it's very sad but
Hillary's um so some of the reasons that
things have changed are really because
of these two forces one forces
information so we have this explosion
and information you have the ability to
have access to as much data as you want
right if you don't have analytics if you
don't search data right look for dinner
sets around your industry you should so
this is really overwhelming if you want
to look at 30 trillion URLs I don't even
know what trillion looks like never
tried going to give me Detroit dollars
okay with that and then the other forces
really increase in access so if you look
at these numbers think of all the people
who are getting online who did not get
online before right 1.5 million android
activations per day that's a lot more
people coming up on
didn't they went online for these are
new customers these are different types
of customers these are customers
accessing your device and your
application your website your business
through multiple devices this is a new
segment of the market that did not exist
that was that long ago ah how many
people remember life before bones cell
phones we had one of those in like a
suitcase in the car like a las younger
for emergencies I think it costs like
forty dollars or minutes and it was
never charged never worked nothing to
use it but it was really cool um still
going internet searches globally and
this is actually another step up here is
fifteen percent of searches every single
day are new so fifteen percent of the
searches that Google sees on a daily
basis have never been searched before
that's actually very interesting you
think of search as kind of a segment
thing people looking up recipes people
looking up information on a very flat
level but a lot of these are brand new
searches okay so with always information
how do we make useful abuse of it so
information is as powerful essentially
as your ability to use it so that's what
we're going to talk about today's how do
you use your data and we're even going
to have been sort of tell us how do you
use your data he's like Godfather
grandfather of the internet he's very
nice you ever get a chance to me he's
like really cozy grandfather like um
okay so we're going to talk two forces
first for the two segments first is the
macro data my compliments economics and
math background and I love let's talk
about economics you guys are the fact
that they don't have to but macro theta
this is all the forces in the world all
of the industry forces all of the
demographic forces the financial forces
that are having an impact on your
business so first of all I'm going to
show you some tools it's up to you to
figure out how to use them for your
business these are tools hopefully I
used to do this I'll do it again I'll
give you guys 10
learn something during this presentation
all right my challenge the one year I
think I would have like four euros on me
so that I really have to do well um how
many guys I've heard about google public
data Explorer yes already okay so this
is a tool basically what it is this
government data and data that's publicly
available to the world that has never
been put in usable format data from the
UN data from the US government from the
eurozone so I'm going to go here you can
just find them set google public data
Explorer so i'll show you their example
um here on the site so this is actually
just showing from the world economic
indicators life expectancy via country
and over time this is pretty cool um how
many of you guys ready phone was a map
tool okay these are basically open
public data sets this tool you can
actually use you can actually ingest
your own data and use these graphical
tools I'll show you them really quickly
here very good wool this is one on the
world this is the one across time so if
you want to explore data sets and think
about this if you let's imagine that
this is the country or a state or the
region that you do the best in has a
particular broad broadband penetration
has a particular level of Android
devices or iOS devices has a particular
amount of disposable income right these
are factors like let's say a country
that you choose to enter or contribute
use to focus on you want it to look like
what how could you find other countries
like how do you measure the forces that
look into the world so you look good
unemployment super exciting you guys
don't have to worry about an employment
hearing self-employed um marriage
divorce mortality population but
essentially what you can do in this tool
is find some of the interesting data
will have an impact on your business so
to get unemployment rate let's imagine
you have an application or a game that
people spend a lot of time on with our
unemployed right like space bug or like
tell me an application that you guys
have this you know your vet games games
yeah see if you don't have a job in fill
our game so let's pick up some countries
here seem real quickly how this changes
so we can see sort of this over time we
can see it on a graph like I've said but
you can actually get really really
detailed if you go down to age group you
can go by age group with it so maybe you
want to certain about it people in a
certain category this is the other
reason that this tool is great is if you
are going towards investors investors
always want to know about trends that
impact your business and how whatever
decision you're making is about those
trends right that's something to
consider I'll let you guys do more with
this tool like I said you can also
ingest idea as well private all right
how about Google Trends maybe what you
used google trends support okay this is
actually my favorite tool I'll show you
some really cool things on robust and
they keep changing it so it just got new
this week this is a problem with life
that most girls always changing product
so I'd stand up kind of like a that's
not out yesterday no idea what happened
so just go to Google Trends what this is
is essentially google search data across
all of google's platforms so we also
provide search for other search engines
as well and ask like AOL com a bunch of
those different groups so this isn't
really accurate search data you go to
this explore section so I got some
examples here say digital digital
publishing I thought to suppose okay so
I talked to John when earlier was
interested in digital publishing if you
want to look here you can see sort of
this over time this graph over time and
then you can look down here over city
and region and then you can see rising
search terms so like potentially adobe
digital publishing and whatnot
we can also add terms or sorry we're
going to add location sorry about that
so we're basically taking all of google
search data and adding filters so that
you can see better information not sure
why time ranges so we'll say I've 12
months so I come down here I can see
over the past 12 months sort of the
change the change in time if I wanted to
I can actually do this where I go two
thousand thirteen thousand twelve two
thousand eleven alright so i can see how
this industry has changed over time so
i'm saying so we're looking at digital
publishing over these years in the US so
what's interesting about this is how
does this help you make decisions if we
pull out let's say the US and say know
how i go back to the world they just
changed this one hey we're just going to
pretend ah but essentially what you
could do is where do you focus your
marketing dollars what do you focus your
effort these are people who are already
searching for whatever you're providing
so it's worth noting you can also look
at seasonality so it appears that people
look for digital publishing more in
January left in june july and then more
in the upper ranges right so if you're
going to allocate your financial
resources or your personal time you
would look at that graph alright so this
is my pendant business we do outdoor
design spatial design has been and I
well plus again I just play with the
numbers mostly but if you look at for us
for example there this huge cyclical
factor right in our business that
changes how we spend our money and how
we spend our resources we should pretty
much just go on holiday I'm like October
through December you should just go on
vacation not work at all there's nothing
going on um anyone else have an example
actually I wanted to show you one more
thing and this is a real example it
helps a guy in the US you would live it
was in New Orleans he runs a macaroon
company and macaroons are not as popular
outside of friends they are a well-known
and we were looking at new areas for him
to create opportunity for his business
he says that on search in the US he is
completely saturated right he cannot
like can i buy more keywords again do
anything else can fit on anything else
and so he looked here at this map we can
see actually Canada has more search
volume than the US right so even though
his business is us he should consider
like big figure I'm going to ship his
business to Canada like to ship some of
his products Canada if he can figure out
Australia there's a huge opportunity
there as well right um a lot of times
this is a great tool to learn about
those new industries and also to learn
how people in like in Australia or learn
all people in a certain place are
actually searching for things so if I
were you guys I would definitely take
time to look at this I think it's really
great up here to which we did look at is
all categories so if you're not certain
about what search you can actually get
super super specific okay well there's
no macaroons in auto the car but if we
pull up auto a car you can just even see
these basic search basic search trends
and then you can actually look at like
specific vehicles so save bicycles and
accessories so look at the stick
cyclical nature of this searches right
pipes go up and down so if i were you i
would spend time on a monthly basis to
look and see what treasures are that are
affecting your business your industry on
a yearly basis when you're planning look
at those spikes if you have a travel
site look at what days of the week
people travel look for travel most there
is our two days of the week there are I
she gave of the one close to holidays
that will factor it you want to be smart
about the time resources that you spend
and how they have to get out yes yeah
guys like this girls shopping
all right this is another really cool
tool and it's called google thing
insights anybody know what this is I
think I'm going to save my three euros
that I have it's good i need take the
subway back so basically what this is
google actually Commission's a lot of
research to be done right research what
industries received about the net web
how this trees are functioning this
website has like a ridiculous amount of
things going on for it you don't hear
you can actually see like above case
studies but there's a ton of data so
this is actually going to tell you all
the mobile stats for brains this is a
study on mobile set Francis's store
insights from Keystone Excel uses of
phones by cars these are all these
studies that have been commissioned
right fifty-five percent of smug
smartphone owners and prints access to
it and it's a leaf of a device fifty
percent of impressions delivered by
YouTube reach people for exclusive TV so
you just think about like all there's a
whole repository a really great data
specific to industries you just search
like four countries for industries all
of the data that would be commissioned
and all the industry reports right there
so it's super cool really like concise
they have a go infographic creator here
as well very interesting at the end of
the day what i would do is figure out
what sources it could not have been BD
sources are reliable for you for data
right like what numbers do you need to
know every month a recorder in order to
figure out how to spend your time and
your money and your resources and how to
make your products better this is
another one which i won't go through but
um focused on sort of global mobile
trends and local devices it's called
think mobile for our mobile clinic
electrical on global climate' it's also
a site created by people that has a ton
of likes mobile specific trends and data
um if you think about all these
marketplaces in the world they're often
cheaper ways for you to get customers
right there's a Chrome Web Store there's
there's the google apps marketplace
there's a whole bunch of these also a
lot of good market places to get things
done cheaper right so 99designs this is
a marketplace for designers this is
about your data your data as a company
how do you deal with your data how do
you make sense of it so this is a great
toys moment favorite examples you can't
tell very well on this but who knows
this top box at Google that's basically
our most coveted most prized position
right on Google right if you can manage
to bid and also have a high quality
score you have a very top of Google
right the color of that box anybody want
to tell me what the color can't see it
very well your color of that box anybody
in color it's kind of like pink fleshy
like peach it's pretty ugly right like
who would have guessed that the most
expensive real estate on our site would
be teach I would never guess that's
right since terrible um actually over
the years that color has changed I make
use of the same color blues greens
oranges yellows all different colors and
the reason is because we have goals
every website everything on your website
or your application should have a goal
the goal of our most important game
states to do two things it is to first
of all not annoy you right if this was
bright red or fluorescent green you'd be
like oh my god this is awful I hate
google that is the worst color ever and
you would go to use some other search
engine which I don't even know it's out
there ah but the other goal is to make
money right we want people if this is a
good advertisement to choose to click on
it correct so those are the two goals so
with those two goals in mind this was
the color that we came up with in the
short term and we make this hopping can
probably get more people to click on it
right for two days then they would never
come by when you have what a
gratification a website you have the
most important elements
your site you have to test you have to
try different things I would never have
chosen this color my instinct would be
wrong this is the like through the data
this is the color that were chosen
because it does it achieve our two goals
right so now I'm going to play a little
game everybody ready to play this game I
love games and we're going to talk about
like how wrong your intuition is right
this is the point of this game it's like
breaking one of the game is for you to
be wrong alright so back in 2008 when
Obama ran for president in the u.s.
there was a group that helped him
optimize his website they use it to a
cold website optimizer which no longer
exists it's now called content
experiments it's in analytics you want
me to write a bit done for your will
very complicated there's also a non
google products both optimizely
basically what it allows you to do is AP
test ABC test so to test different
versions of your site's towards a goal a
lot of people test our website and have
no goal you have no goal you should shut
it down go right so the goal of this
site was to get more people to sign up
right get more people to sign up to
volunteer which if you'll see at the
bottom and to get more people to donate
money and he also wanted volunteers so
their goal is like he wants people to
come to this site take action right and
then we want them to subsequently
continue on that site donate money like
volunteer those things okay so you guys
are all going to vote there's two things
that were tested the image the large
image which you can see there and this
this red button so i'm going to show you
first the images you're going to vote on
1 through 3 i'm going to show you four
buttons number is even gets it right
there's nothing to win except awesome
right so moving boats number one okay
great who votes number two okay great
Kubo's number three okay all right yeah
and ready so these are the options it
was no sign up votes the button sign up
was the most effective 11 guys you guys
good way to stick your conviction number
to learn more okay you more number three
join us now solid number four sign up
now okay so what I'm going to show you
is a very old interface of the website
optimizer so what we can see here is the
combination that was most effective is
the family image which I'll go back
there and then the button will learn
more and the results of this so the
Delta what we need is the trajectory of
the first site versus that end result of
the second sight so the difference was
actually 2.8 more subscriptions 2.8 more
people signed million people signed up
57 million dollars more was donated
based on a button and an image ok so the
original one I'll show you this one was
actually the original one right here so
it looks good right it doesn't look like
the family image will go back to over
there that doesn't look 57 million
dollars more awesome does it I mean it
definitely doesn't but it actually was
so what I'm my message here is you have
to trust the data sometimes they're like
our intuition is that we made a website
and made an application and it's amazing
and we love it and your mom loves it and
your wife loves in your girlfriend loves
it but the reality is if the users love
it right small small changes can make a
huge impact
your site's my recommendations if you're
going to test is test the most important
things if you notice she didn't change
the entire site even though it looks
like it the fields are the same it's
just the image in the button is that
what matters so things discussed on your
site like the more simple the better the
less text the better less fields the
better consolidating the first
experience so this was the first
experience I'm sure after this he had to
sign up for something else you're going
to enter a credit card you had to do
something to pay this person but the
reality is that first experience that
entry point was really easy and it was
testing it was something that was gated
ribbon so in Alden convince you to all
test your website um he used to google
and all the next time I people use
google analytics in here it's free and
it's amazing so um I would definitely
use it I use it love it how I use this
tool functionally I also use Adwords so
every day I get an email there's custom
reports you can set up custom reports in
analytics and I don't think it to number
is sent to me every day because there's
so much data and analytics right when
you get in there you're like whoa this
is really confusing and I don't even
know what I care about anymore before
you open your analytics account you
should write down literally not joking
write down the questions that you have
like where is my company to invest how
much are my cost per conversion where's
my traffic coming from which social
media outlets which of the social medias
I'm doing are not just bringing the most
traffic but bringing the most
conversions right like you need to think
about what data is actually meaningful
to your business and the rest of it just
worry about on a quarterly basis because
you can't you honestly just can't ingest
that much information I get on a daily
basis so I set up automated emails
custom reports every single day and I
get cost per conversion every day and
basically number of conversions then on
a weekly basis I look up
because that's really all I hear about
me everything else is just noise and
it's useful noise but it's not useful
every day right not used to every minute
speed so I think about that with
analytics do do do set up custom
reporting don't come to your email or
your phone or whatever you want and
think about that if you have to have two
pieces of information every morning it
would help you make a better business
what would they be more than three and
there went down because it will help you
drive letter customers better user is
whatever it is that you do it will make
the customer experience and your
experience better um this is a Randy tip
of the day if you have internal search
on people have internal search on their
website or application ever they were
down okay people never look at internal
search and analytics is basically if you
have a search box inside of your actual
website those are people telling you
exactly what they're looking for and if
they can't find it um if you match that
plus like keywords and come to your site
there's a lot of interesting analysis
you can be there and individual basis so
i would consider yeah okay last area
promise I'll sit down this is really
about social United social you have a
community of people hopefully like a
social community and other community
that are influencers most people treat
not only every single social medium but
every single like user the same that's
something wrong like this is a google
ripples which is in google+ essentially
what it shows is when i post something
this is not me postings on on fidelio
mama which is actually person post this
kind of weary but essentially when i
post something who are the people that
are actually sharing who are having the
biggest influence right those people are
influencers those are my salesman those
are my marketers those are my people who
are out there like selling my products
for me I should not ignore them they
should be different right they're like
literally three salesman free marketing
people to you so I will tell you a
little lesson here this is google docs
we have people every single day or not
goodbye hope you spend hours and hours
literally their entire day almost
contributing to the Google Docs boring
they are not google employees they just
love our products they are just like
those people who are here to work
influencers they are the same people who
are really in love with our products we
send them shui cinema tickets to google
i/o when there's a problem we call them
we have their email addresses we engage
with these people because they are our
front line right there are other people
who are making our products better we
call them up how do we fix the product
what's going on you see it sure here you
see a problem there you need to take
care of the people who are taking care
of you and those influencers so people
have a lot movie share your posts your
tweets whatever it is I don't ignore
them get in touch them individually and
say hey I want your product feedback I
want to have a relationship with you
right I want to talk to you because they
are like literally free employees these
are people who are working every day to
make dogs better without our guidance
right so do not ignore those people and
that most people are in your data so you
don't take time to look at the data
that's influencing your business you
will not find out so rather than that
you um it was my my last but best slide
um the other thing I think about with
data is is a lot of people look at
crowdsource funding as a way to make
money right how many of you guys have
ever had a crowdsource fun funding
campaign you guys know oppressors
funding is okay so essentially you make
a video a video a pitch about your
product you put it online this is a
cycle IndieGoGo which is actually global
you can connect she's Padres here you
sit it out there you try to send it to
your whole network and get people to
donate funds to submit funds to your
project or a business idea or here
whatever you do like Kickstarter um
often know what people do is if you
donate let's say five hero I think this
guy was like five dollars he will
actually send you the first version of
his product for free I will give you a
really x
to the application these are people who
are willing to thank our product that
does not exist and may never exist right
this is real validation this real
customer validation this is people who
are willing to pay for your products
before you created it that's data its
data about 62 million 572 dollars worth
of money that somebody gave to you based
on your product idea without even the
product or based on the idea the hope
that it will exist and help get it so
what I would consider the reason I like
this example a little bit funny I'm
gonna play this video for you is because
his man is 78 years old is there anyone
in here that's older than 78 okay so he
can make it crowd source funding
campaign so can you and he is actually
pretty rich she's already made a product
that's got done very very well and he
could go out there on his own and build
a product and send it to market without
any help from any of us right but he was
like I'm not quite sure people really
want this and I'm wondering if they're
willing to pay for it so I want to raise
money just to see and that's what he did
i'm going to show you this video because
it's super funny um and how many of you
guys think you should created how
professors funny after this yeah okay
well we're at that time I there's no
really good videos especially on
IndieGoGo site tell you like good tips
and tricks for raising funds but I would
always think of this as data and will
often think of it as fundraising but
it's very different don't cry lets rule
one dogs are adorable they'll eat
everything that's why we invented world
the solution that helps cure dog friend
in less than a minute dog bad breath is
one of the major concerns of dog owners
all we can really recommend is to brush
their teeth
they rocks don't like it even when they
let me brush their teeth it won't solve
the problem studies show that ninety
percent of bad breath and humid comes
from the tongue I'm dr. Bob ten years
ago I invented Orabrush a tongue cleaner
that helps cure bedroom after people
started using the Orabrush for
themselves they requested that we create
an Orabrush to their done brushing my
work are gone natha that'd be good
wouldn't it how do you get dogs let you
its tongue you don't you let the dog to
it having a system where the dog will
clean so Trump is very beneficial to
both the army and to the dough it's not
a chore it's more like a tree ultra-soft
widget bristles cool funny all right
thing ah but it's really interesting I
mean hundreds of thousands of people
contributed to this campaign in order to
buy one of these what the products
existed so that's real customer data why
were you I would definitely reconsider
my anything found crowd source funding
it's not just about getting funds it's
really about like creating those first
customers creating those influencers of
people who are going to go out there and
talk about your products they're willing
to give you money on a home right that's
pretty incredible so I would think about
this question like what data drives your
startup there's a lot of data out there
you should always have like two numbers
every morning you wake up to that help
you make the decisions and you should
always think about what are the macro
courses what are the industry world
courses that make my business very
successful or make my business
unsuccessful right um cuz I think too
often we we know that there's data out
there but we don't take the time to make
it meaningful to us and then you guys
are startup have limited time you need
to figure out how to do that so here's
my exciting take place it's basically
what i just said should just turn to the
slide and that's it i'm here all day i'm
happy to talk about pretty much anything
as you see i like talking so that's not
a problem for me um but i'm really glad
you guys joined us
we really hope to add value each cooler
years is here to add value to your
company today so please take advantage
of that opportunity thank you very much